[Applaudissements]
mon nom est julien vidal et si je suis
ici devant vous c'est pour vous dire que
nous tous nous avons énormément de
chance si nous avons énormément de
chance et en fait on partage un talent
en commun qui va nous permettre de
changer le monde mais pour que je vous
explique un peu où je veux en venir
il va falloir que je vous parle de moi
si je devais faire mon autoportrait
je dirais pas que je suis quelqu'un
d'extraordinaire tu pas un génie avec un
qi exceptionnelle et si j'ai réussi à
aller au bout de mes études
c'est plutôt parce que j'ai une bonne
mémoire je suis pas non plus un sportif
force hors pair pardon on va pas se
mentir
j'adore le sport mais je sais que mon
mètre 73 et moi nous ne serons jamais
appelé par l'équipe nationale bat skate
pour aller aux jeux olympiques
non je sais après difficile de vous dire
que je suis quelqu'un de normal parce
que finalement je ne sais pas vraiment
ce que ça veut dire d'être quelqu'un de
normal ce qui est sûr c'est que des
personnes comme moi il y en a plein mais
tout à l'heure je vous disais qu'on
avait de la chance et si on a de la
chance c'est parce que je pense qu on
partage tous cette force en commun
qu'est la curiosité vous qui êtes venus
ce soir
moi qui suis ici devant vous toute ma
vie je me suis posé énormément de
questions et c'est le premier jour de
mon master 2 que notre directeur
d'études est venu et nous a dit je vous
souhaite à tous vous vous posez beaucoup
plus de questions à la fin de cette
année quand la commençant que pour moi
ça a été un déclic je me suis dit oui
c'est évident j'ai raison de me poser
des questions et j'ai envie de continuer
à composer et du coup ce que j'ai fait
j'ai essayé plein de trucs différents
et puis surtout j'ai voyagé j'ai compris
que le voyage c'est une manière
extraordinaire d'assouvir sa curiosité
petit à petit les voyages ont laissé la
place aux missions humanitaires
je partais à l'étranger pour donner à
mali le sens que je ne le trouvais pas
vraiment en france
jusqu'ici tout allait bien ma vie était
sur des rails
aucun problème jusqu'à un moment où tout
a été chamboulé et pour que vous
compreniez bien il faut que je vous
emmène avec moi imaginez un peu vous
êtes aux philippines les philippines
ça fait un an que j'ai vu c'est une
véritable machine à laver à émotion une
montagne russe même avec d'un côté la
pauvreté des bidonvilles remplie de
centaines de milliers de personnes
la détresse des jeunes adultes exclu
avec lesquels je travaille au quotidien
et d'un autre comme vous pouvez le voir
une nature sauvage préservée luxuriante
extraordinaire je profite de mes
vacances pour aller découvrir ses
trésors
je suis sur un bateau je laisse ma
pensée naviguer au fil de l'eau et tout
d'un coup sans crier gare je me retrouve
à penser à l'après
je m'imagine dans un an je serai de
retour en france j'ai envie de m'y
installer
et tout d'un coup c'est la panique
c'est la panique c'est pas parce que je
suis sur un bateau fait de bambou et que
ça fait une heure qu'on navigue non
c'est la panique parce que je me rends
compte qu'en fait j'ai aucune idée de la
presse je m'imagine rentrer en france
je sais déjà la question que tout le
monde aime poser bon ça fait cinq ans
que tu essayes de sauver le monde à
l'étranger maintenant je vais pouvoir
trouver un vrai travail alors qu'en fait
pour moi les questions c'est pas du tout
ça est question c'est je rentre en
france
j'ai envie de donner du sens à mon
quotidien comment je fais et puis vous
savez cette fameuse boulot dodo
quel équilibre jtrouve puis en plus j'ai
beau vivre à l'être je vois bien qu'en
ce moment est français c'est pas du tout
facile il ya qu'allumer l'atp le
terrorise violence corruption
les catastrophes naturelles ok ok on est
d'accord
le monde va mal et puis en plus on sait
que ça va aller en empirant
on est quand même en passe d'atteindre
un point de non retour
au niveau environnemental mais du coup
moi ma vraie question c'est dans cet
état de tension extrême
comment je fais pour vivre tout en
participant à la construction d'un monde
meilleur en étant comme vous et moi
c'est quand même une sacrée question et
puis je me suis dit que finalement
j'avais de la chance je vais pouvoir
rentrer en france
et puis en fait je vais pouvoir me
mettre à tous espionnés pesé mesuré
audités puisque finalement la france est
un pays où je n'ai plus vraiment
d'habitude tout ce que ma vie entraîne
en sortie en déplacement en consommation
en shopping en loisir je vais tout
sculpté avec ces trois poids
le premier c est ce que cette action me
rend heureux le deuxième c'est est ce
que cette action respecte la dignité des
autres êtres humains le troisième c est
ce que cette action est respectueuse de
l'environnement
et c'est ce que j'ai fait eurêka c'était
mon idée je me suis dit et si finalement
changé le monde passait
à part aller à l'autre bout de la
planète et si finalement changer le
monde
on pouvait faire chez soi et y trouver
du sens et si finalement c'était 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 par toutes
nos actions qu'on pouvait construire un
monde meilleur
et si finalement faire bouger les choses
s'étaient pas se changer un peu soi même
et si finalement ça a commencé par mois
et du coup je me suis lancé dans ce
projet un peu fou de créer ça commence
par moi puisque je me disais j'ai envie
de faire ça mais je sais très bien ce
qui va se passer et besoin d'un cadre
j'avais besoin d'une rigueur j'avais
besoin de quelque chose qui me fasse
tenir dans la durée
parce que je m'imaginais déjà avec le
boulot le froid qui arrive les 8 plus en
plus courte
après mes 40 degrés aux philippines
pendant deux ans et je savais qu'au bout
d'un moment j'ai la voir la flemme
j'allais être happé par le quotidien et
que cette super idée j'allais les a
laissés tomber et donc du coup je me
suis dit et si je ne partageais pas à
ceux que ça intéresse ça commence par
mois c'est depuis le 1er septembre 2016
sur internet que je mets en ligne tous
les jours
une manière d'améliorer mon quotidien un
mois et de participer à la construction
d'un monde meilleur
et puis je en fait comme on peut le
faire pas besoin d'un doctorat en
ingénierie du changement pas besoin
d'être multi millionnaire non tout le
monde avec ses talents sa créativité
mais aussi ses disponibilités peut
changer le monde au quotidien
et puis avec ce projet vraiment
l'exemplarité la clé je veux pas du tout
que les gens pensent que je fais mieux
que que je suis meilleur que je sais
mieux non moi aussi j'ai mes défauts
j'ai mes responsabilités j'ai mon
travail tous les jours
chacun part de sa propre situation
l'important c'est d'avancer
à mi chemin si mon projet déjà je
composte je suis passé banques éthiques
j'achète dans un supermarché
collaboratif
je consomme de l'électricité verte j'ai
toujours une gourde avec moi je me
déplace à vélo quand c'est possible
bref tous les jours je change le monde
à mi parcours nous avons déjà 180
actions concrètes pour changer le monde
à l'échelle de l'individu 181 actions
180 excuse pour s'y mettre
petites ou grandes gratuite ou onéreuse
alors oui vous allez me dire très bien
mais parmi ces 181 actions
on est quand même d'accord il y en a qui
permettent de changer le monde plus que
d'autres oui tout à fait on est d'accord
mais le plus important dans tout ça en
fait c'est que changer le monde c'est un
peu comme ouvrir un pot de crème de
marron mais si vous savez quand on l'a
ouvert impossible de s'arrêter
on s'était juré qu'on allait prendre une
cuillère et ben non on continue et on
continue c'est pareil quand on veut
changer le monde en fait c'est vraiment
notre créativité qui est notre seule
limite
et puis en août à mi parcours comme je
vous le disais six mois de projets déjà
si je devais faire un premier bilan
je dirais que j'ai appris deux choses la
première c'est que oui la nature est
belle et que non nous n'avons pas besoin
de temps ni d'argent pour changer le
monde
elle est même très belle et surtout très
très très bien fait
puissant fait quand on la suit
naturellement on se retrouve à gagner en
pouvoir d'achat à gagner du temps et
surtout à gagner en qualité de vie c'est
incroyable mais je vous promets que
c'est le cas et la deuxième chose si je
pouvais vous souhaiter à tous quelque
chose dans cette salle ça serait de tout
questionner tout le temps moi ça m'a
permis de me réapproprier ma vie finie
la routine si vous mettez a utilisé ses
deux armes que sont les quoi et les
commet
chaque jour est une nouvelle surprise
comprendre plutôt que de posséder et si
c'était ça vraiment la clé d'une vie
heureuse et épanouie comprendre au lieu
de posséder chose qui me trotte dans la
tête depuis pas mal de temps
et puis aussi ce que je veux dire c'est
que moi j'en ai marre d'arrêter
d'attendre des autres qu'ils changent
les choses à ma place tant pis si mon
voisin ne recycle pas tant pis si mon
boss a un énorme 4,4 pour paix en ville
tant pis si ma copine passe des heures
sous la douche tous les matins oui je
sais j'y suis allé un peu fort avec les
clichés
moi même je suis pas parfait après six
mois d'introspection j'ai encore
énormément de boulot et je veux que tous
les jours au quotidien je fais encore
des choses qui sont contraires à mes
valeurs
la tenait pour vous dire je vous donne
un exemple on était juste avant dallas
dans la salle de préparation
eh bien j'ai bu de l'eau d'une bouteille
en plastique plutôt que de boire de
l'eau du robinet
c'est un détail vous allez me dire et
pourtant c'est vraiment tous ces petits
changements qui permettent selon moi de
changer le monde
bon après je vais pas vous mentir ça
commence par mois oblige j'ai récupéré
le bouchon en plastique et ça c'est pour
ceux qui ne savent pas vous allez sur le
blog c'est l'article du 13 février
je vais pas vous mentir je me rends
compte tous les jours
changer le monde c'est hyper difficile
puisqu'en fait ça veut dire se changer
soi même
il en faut un sacré paquet du courage
pour s'y mettre vraiment il en faut
vraiment c'est hyper difficile c'est
vrai et pourtant c'est possible
et puis en plus on le voit la société
évolue en ce moment est de plus en plus
on a des opportunités des outils pour
nous mettre nous aussi à faire bouger
les choses
d'autant que je suis sûr que vous tous
vous souhaitez qu'une chose c'est mon
maire je suis sûr que vous tous ici vous
souhaitez un monde plus heureux je suis
sûr que vous tous ici vous souhaitez un
monde plus égalitaire
je suis sûr que vous tous ici vous
souhaitez un monde plus respectueux de
la planète
alors allons-y moi personnellement j'ai
fait le pari de me dire que de petites
actions valent mieux que de ne pas agir
pour construire un monde meilleur
réapproprions nous le pouvoir de changer
les choses à notre échelle à l'échelle
de l'individu
car changer le monde ça commence par soi
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]